[Musique]
la délégation aux droits des femmes tous
les ans on essaye d'organiser des
événements au moment du 8 mars journée
internationale droits des femmes cette
année nous avons décidé avec serge
babary président de la délégation aux
entreprises de faire un événement commun
un événement fort autour de l'entreprise
autour des femmes dans l'entreprise aura
deux tables rondes successives l'une
animé par ma collègue annie billon sur
l'orientation la formation
on l'a bien vu notamment avec la réforme
du bac c'est une polémique actuellement
les jeunes filles s'oriente - vers les
filières mathématiques et c'est un enjeu
majeur pour retrouver des femmes
ingénieures à des postes à
responsabilités aussi dans les
entreprises dans les grosses entreprises
pour ma part je n'aimerais une table
ronde sur la mixité dans l'entreprise et
la façon de permettre aux femmes de
prendre des responsabilités et d'être
représenté dans un certain nombre de
métiers où elles sont peu présentes